do you feel and i've always wanted to
ask you this do you feel
asian like does it feel asian when you
wake up no no no that's a that's a funny
thing that's a good question dude that's
ridiculous is it really yeah because i
wake up i don't even think about it
really yeah this is what the first i i
think what time is it
every time i wake up what time is it
right and then i go that's what i think
where's my phone it's the second thing
yeah and then the third thing is i got
to pee yeah me too then the fourth thing
is i need to get some coffee or
something yeah i need something to get
me up or water or something sort of
liquids yeah something like any liquid
right
then the fifth thing is am i asian
is this racist do chinese people have
guess who
on wednesday nasa launched the space
shuttle columbia on its 87th voyage this
trip by the shuttle will feature the
first spacewalk ever by a japanese
astronaut who will get to take in the
unique perspective of earth from space
gee i wonder if there's any chance he'll
uh take a picture
are you all mexican the [ __ ] are y'all
[Applause]
what are you
you're arabic y'all came out here
you blend the [ __ ] in huh
holy [ __ ] dude
these arabic guys are good
i could have swore y'all were mexican
you got the flannel and [ __ ]
this guy ready to go
[Laughter]
y'all are middle eastern your middle
eastern young middle east i'm not
mexican at all you a little bit i can
see you the most
he's just chilling in a cut quiet but
you two guys could be mexican you are
mexican right damn bro
you thought you had a squad bro you
thought
you thought you meant the essence bro
nah you got played dog
gotta [ __ ] play bro
what type of middle east turned up
palestinian oh [ __ ]
does that exist i'm joking
i heard a jew laugh really loud over
there
[Applause]
you know that one lap
wow
now that was a good one i like that joke
very funny
ugh
we found one mexican
you're just holding it down for us away
i hear you bro
i don't even know if i believe you're
mexican now
what do you got
what are you busting out
a cross
they got christian palestinians you ever
heard of jesus
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] it you're right bro
that [ __ ] was from there
what about you guys man you're a mexican
you gotta be
i got that [ __ ] down
but you're not you're asian
what type of asian are you
what
what
did you just say your last name
you're from pong
is that near ping
no wonder you're so good at that [ __ ]
no pong is a type of asian
oh monk
huh
son y'all know that one bro
asian miss
did you know that one
hmong
do we have you in new york
i usually know my asian [ __ ]
this is new to me
mom
what from what country if you say hmong
i'm gonna flip out
miss did you really know about this are
you mom too
you're chinese and vietnamese all right
i know those normal
this one over here is nuts
they're the palestinians of asians bro
you're not even sure if they really
existed
wait the monk but where is mom
[Music]
it's okay you'll get there one day
keep on keeping on
bob hope make god laugh
so i stopped at him like hey jimmy bob
hope never played the [ __ ] laugh
he's like oh yeah
i'm like what and he's like one time he
came in man and he said to me uh can i
do five minutes i say can you do five
minutes you bob hope
is he chinese i know i can't do them
every time i do them people say that
sounds like a [ __ ] and i go that's
not a nice thing to call asians
you know i'm a big fan of asians i think
they're the best group i think they're
number one i don't think they get the
credit they deserve i'm an asian
supremacist all the way i think they're
better than the rest any asian people
here
hey all right you should be working come
on
what are you doing having a good time
that's not the asian i know god damn it
i want you dealing blackjack or sitting
on a box peeling something come on
big fan best group easily the best group
no love you guys get the short on the
chopstick it's pretty unfair
so quiet so secure asians every other
group's got to brag and boast every
group's got a slogan black people i'm
black and i'm proud white people white
power hispanics
[Applause]
not an asian ninja's head down grades up
that's it
angel the bet you never hear about asian
crime never if i was an asian guy i'd
just start mugging people like hey it's
my word against yours
are you chinese
yes what's uh where is your family from
taiwan taiwan so you were made in taiwan
do you speak mandarin yeah and and your
girl she's
this girl you're not his girl oh damn
wow
wow that's [ __ ] up
you can at least pretended you know to
make him feel like a man
you didn't have to [ __ ] emasculate
him in front of everybody
and your girl i'm not his [ __ ] girl
please
you wish
i see that [ __ ] i see it all around
blacks and whites don't fight so much
you know who don't have no beef with
anybody's asian people i see how y'all
be doing
[Music]
yeah i just lay in the cut
i want all the time all people asian
people beef with is other asian people
like if you call a korean guy chinese
i've done this they will flip out hey
[Applause]
what make you think of chinese
i am korean
i look chinese
yes [ __ ] you do look chinese
that's why i said it
it's an accident look at the untrained
now you all look chinese to me
it's a mistake i'm not trying to offend
you some people say all black people
look alike we don't get bent out of
shape we normally just call those people
police okay
just learn to live with it that's all i
can tell